[Musique]
le premier ministre vous avez été
désigné par le président de la
république pour former le nouveau
gouvernement
quel est votre programme pour le moment
je n'ai aucun programme ça dépendra déjà
de ce que mes confrères ou choisiront et
j'essayerai de voir quels sont les mais
quels sont les meilleurs plans si je
peux appeler ça comme ça qu'il me
présenteront pourquoi est ce que le
président de la république a démissionné
votre précis dans votre précédent
ministère je ne sais pas exactement il
n'a pas voulu me le dire
vous entretenez de bonnes relations avec
le président de la république
ça dépend j'espère hollande en avoir de
bonnes avec lui mais j'espère surtout
que ça dépendra de ce que je vais dire
est de cela qu est ce que vous allez
faire vous personnellement je n'ai rien
prévu de spécial
bénard au moins
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez qu'un premier
ministre quand il est désigné a prévu
quelque chose s'il désignait comme j'ai
comme j'ai été désigné tout de suite
comme ça j'ai pas pu prévoir grand chose
mais je le garde des sceaux
qu'est ce qu'un saut un garde des sceaux
quelqu'un qui s'occupe du gouvernement
pour eux et guernesey mais bon monsieur
le garde des sceaux je sens que vous
connaissez parfaitement bien vos
affaires vous savez exactement ce que
vous allez faire dans ce gouvernement
quel est votre programme tout d'abord je
vais je vais proposer à mon premier
ministre de retirer la peine de mort
après ce qui se passe
par rapport au programme précédent
quelle différence va t il y avoir entre
votre action de demain et l'action du
précédent ministre de la santé
pratiquement rien j'aimerais bien
augmenter plus les patrons pour qu'ils
puissent reprendre et reconstruire des
choses en plus pour pour boucher le
chômage +0 gros salaire moyen de chômage
voilà c'est ça moi je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord je pense plutôt qu'il
faudrait réduire le chômage en donnant
plutôt des primes de pouvoir construire
des usines votre programme je pense à 15
h et sera c'est chouette ce que les
fruits sont baissés et fabrique un peu
trop de fruits pommes et les poires
alors faute grave sinon je me mettrais
un peu plus de légumes et des oranges
dans le midi
que pensez-vous de ternell c'est un bon
joueur je trouve
est ce que vous vous dopez aux non je ne
vois pas à quoi ça survivre à ça peut
servir dans un sport mais pour un
ministère je vous vois vraiment pas
l'utilité
je vais la coopération voilà il faudrait
bien qu'on se conçoit bien avec tous les
pays pour notamment pour avec ramasseurs
audit là pour le pétrole parce qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup brillé avec 26,2 il faut
qu'on ne faut pas prendre il faut qu'on
soit bien avec eux ventes et un
sacrifices qu'on aille au bout de
pétrole qu'est-ce que vous avez un
projet sur le plan militaire pour
l'instant fin ça va je crois que là on
va continuer le service militaire est
peut-être d'en rallonger
je ne suis pas d'accord du tout avec
ja confrères en défense parce qu' il
faudrait plutôt réduire le service
militaire et de leurs archives et faire
un service n'était évidemment très court
pour les femmes c'est ce que j'ai à dire
vous qui êtes l'avenir de la france
qu'elle est monsieur le premier ministre
votre idée de la france de demain
mon idée de la france de demain ce
serait qu'il y aura beaucoup moins de
chômage est comme ça ça réduira pas mal
de choses on pourra déjà mieux vivre
c'est qu'il y ait des espaces verts pour
touristes pour qu'il puisse respirer le
bon air de la france comme dans pae prix
et qu'on augmente un peu
[Musique]